hi sal khan here from khan academy and i
just want to remind you that as we get
to the final few days of 2020 which has
been a tough year i think for most of us
there's also the final few days of our
end of year giving campaign
and as we go through those final few
days i want to remind you that khan
academy is a not-for-profit with the
mission of providing a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere we can
only do that work through philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself
and any way you slice it the social
return on every dollar you give is
really off the charts for khan academy
think of the scale think of the tens or
hundreds of millions of folks that khan
academy reaches in over 46 languages
around the world
and if that by itself isn't convincing
enough i'll give you some of my favorite
recent research that i've been looking
at which is how do you become a happier
person and there are some things like
you should sleep enough you should
meditate uh you should have gratitude
but also do random acts of kindness and
a very powerful random act of kindness
would be to donate to khan academy so
not only will it help others tap into
their potential around the world
millions and millions of people
i think it actually might make all of us
happy uh by giving to it as well and
make make you feel good about a strong
way of ending an otherwise tough year
and going into 2021 on a very very
positive footing so if you're in a
position to do so please think about
making a donation to khan academy we
wouldn't be able to do the work we do
without you